what exactly do you understand to have
happened well it appears from the guard
in the mirror that Dominic Cummings the
Prime Minister's closest adviser
travelled over 200 miles to ask his
elderly grandparents to the country's
children when he and his wife had got
coronavirus that looks like it's in real
breach of the rules and when millions of
people have sacrificed so much in order
to stop the spread of crone of ice
people have not seen their loved ones I
had to cancel weddings not being able to
go to the funerals of their closest
relatives
it looks quite outrageous that the Prime
Minister's closest advisor has done this
and frankly if that turns out to be the
case he must go he should either resign
or the Prime Minister should sack him is
there any explanation that you would
accept
well the Prime Minister has got two
obviously look at this urgently and got
to make his position clear because the
buck stops with the Prime Minister on
this appointment I can't see in my
reading of the guidelines this is
anything other than a very severe breach
of those guidelines
I'm always someone who would like to
hear the next nation but I can't see how
Dominic Cummings can wriggle out of this
one and I think he ought to do the
decent thing today and to resign could
it be that it comes under exceptional
circumstances though because we read
that he needed to take his child to his
parents because he was too ill and his
wife also to look after their young
child I don't think that's the case
certainly not according to the
guidelines of what existence when he
made this very long journey and I think
people are also asking questions about
why he would go to his own parents who
were clearly in a vulnerable category I
can't see any way that this could be
under some exemption many people have
had to deal with their children and when
they've been in self-isolation
when they've been abiding by the rules I
don't think there can be one rule for
everyone else and a different rule from
the Prime Minister's top team
can we look though for a moment of the
human circumstances of this I mean what
would you have done if you'd had a young
child that obviously needed to be looked
after and both yourself and your wife
weren't able to do that but what should
he have done we all have sympathy with
people who have these difficult
circumstances the question is what were
the rules and what was open to him I
don't think going right across the
country 2ld relatives or was the
solution it certainly wasn't in the
rules as far as I read them so of course
one has sympathy with people with these
difficult dilemmas but these are the
sorts of things that people were facing
in their Millions and I just don't think
there should be an exception made for
the prime ministers top advisor but
specifically what would you have
suggested as a solution well I actually
think he could have stayed at home with
his wife and with his child I'm pretty
sure that would have been possible and
if not maybe he should have contacted
the NHS or the local authority there are
people out there who are willing to help
in the community who are trained who are
less vulnerable in my own condition see
we've seen the council and the NHS and
the Vaughn tree services providing
amazing support for those who've been
self isolating who've been in need and I
don't see why Dominic Cummings couldn't
have contacted a local experts local
people who could have helped on a wider
question do you think the government now
has the virus under control with the
institution of the quarantine with the
testing testing tracking and tracing is
it under control well I hope it is this
is such a tragedy for so many people but
I fear first of all that we still have
the crisis in our care homes I don't
believe the evidence suggests of that
yet is sorted and I'm very worried about
their strategy on testing tracing in
isolation this is essential so the
lockdown can be lifted so we can get
back to something near normality but it
doesn't appear you
they have got that under control they
haven't got a proper testing tracing and
isolation strategy they haven't geared
up anywhere near enough and without that
it's going to be gonna prove very
difficult to get back to normal life and
I really urge the government they should
have been doing this weeks ago months
ago they've been very slow throughout
this crisis they've really got to get to
grips with this so we can get the
schools to return get everybody back to
work
but it's the in the government's court
to take these final actions which is
being so sure in doing yet we are
hearing from Professor Karl Hannigan
director the Centre for evidence-based
medicine at Oxford University he's
saying that the coronavirus is
disappearing at a rate that's speeding
up well I have very much hope he's right
and I will listen to professors like him
scientists and I hope we can lift the
lockdown but as the Prime Minister keeps
reminding us it's the famous are number
and while that's still very prevalent in
some parts of the country because it's
not the same across the country in the
care homes we've got to be very cautious
I think given the a huge number of
people who have lost their lives during
this crisis far higher than in similar
countries I think it's right to be
cautious and to listen to the scientists
absolutely but to take a cautious
approach and I really worry that there
are voices in the government who are so
desperate to lift the lockdown that
they're not quite listening to the
advice and the evidence